pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrivé à l'école des métiers pour les
jeunes apprentis c'est parfois franchir
un large fossé un fossé entre
l'enseignement classique général au
collège et l'enseignement professionnels
pratiquent à l'école et en entreprise
ici en alternance on vient d'apprendre
un métier pour valériane ce sera la
coiffure il ya longtemps qu'elle y pense
avec des images qui remonte à l'enfance
à chaque fois je regarde c'est là que ça
a commencé
oui qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui te plaisait
dans ce qu'il faudrait à tout j'adorais
regarder qu'on allait poser des couleurs
quand elle coupait les cheveux quand on
est sur cheveux mouillés
on va payer notre joueur pour la démêlés
de la race et de la pointe jusqu'à
l'arrêt c'est à peine trois semaines
après la rentrée valériane c'est qu'elle
a sélectionné la bonne voie et en
entreprise son maître d'apprentissage
n'hésitera pas à la conforter dans son
choix
la voie royale pour apprendre la
coiffure c'est l'apprentissage en ses
dettes dans l'entreprise avec les
clients au quotidien
c'est vraiment la voie royale ça c'est
sûr
aujourd'hui si valériane est dans le
bain ça lui plaît et elle se souvient du
jour où elle a parlé de ses projets à
ses parents ils ont dit que j'allais
oublier dans quelques années ça changera
bon maintenant je fais toujours dans ce
que je voulais faire ils ont fait oui
mais non et changera pas et maintenant
ils sont plutôt contents oui bah oui je
peux leur couper les cheveux
gratuitement
vous avez vu vous distinguer la zone 1 2
et 3 c'est par là qu'il faut commencer
la zone du vertex vous faites votre
séparation ensuite vous voulez vos goûts
tout ça vous pouvez commencer en
entreprise et nous on reprendra à
l'école ce qui peut parfois inquiéter
les parents ça n'est pas le coût des
études l'apprentissage est gratuit mais
c'est la recherche d'une entreprise et
d'un contrat en alternance sur ce sujet
nous avons développé tout un service
structuré chez nous qui permet de
recueillir toutes les offres proposées
par les entreprises et on omet en
rapprochement donc les demandes des
jeunes avec ses ces entreprises qui
recherchent aujourd'hui 120 apprentie
coiffeuse sont inscrits à l'école des
métiers parti jan chan points surtout
celles qui sont sérieuses on va dire
trouvent du travail ça c'est sûr à 100%
derrière exempt du travail elles ont
pratiquement tout pour ambition de
devenir un jour patronne de leur propre
salon valériane elle a le même objectif
mais avec un défi supplémentaire à
relever
ouvrir son propre salon wii mais au
canada